-Welcome back!
I'm talking to
our pal Billie Eilish
right here!
[ Cheering and applause ]
She's got the number 1 album,
"Happier Than Ever."
And, in February, you're going
to go on a sold-out arena tour.
[ Cheering and applause ]
It's already sold out.
Come on!
You must be excited
to go back out there.
-[Contented sigh]
I have had like six dreams
this week about shows.
Dead serious.
-Really?
-Yeah.
It's been so long!
It's going to have been two
and a half years, I guess.
Or two years.
I don't know.
And that's crazy to me,
so I can't wait.
-What songs are you most excited
to perform off the new album?
-Ooh. For sure,
"Happier Than Ever" the song.
-The song you're doing tonight,
"Happier Than Ever," yeah.
-[ Singsong ]
Yes, I am!
[ Cheering and applause ]
And -- [ Laughs ]
-See?
Don't you miss?
I mean, do you miss that?
I mean, you --
Kind of a performer needs.
I mean, when we first
had our audience back --
which, I'm so psyched and happy
that this audience
is back here --
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Whistling ]
...you get emotional,
you get choked up.
And I know I'm going
to come out and tell these,
you know, goofy jokes, you know,
but I really just want to --
I miss them.
I need an audience.
I need my fans.
I need people.
-Yeah, you do.
I mean, it feels
so unsatisfying
and like unrewarding
without one.
But the thing that you're
doing, now,
they did at the Hollywood Bowl,
which is gorgeous,
that comes out September 3rd
on Disney+.
But you shot this
at the Hollywood Bowl,
an empty Hollywood Bowl,
-Yeah, in the middle
of the night.
-and did a great job.
You made it beautiful.
Who directed?
-It was Robert Rodriguez...
-Come on. [ Clap ]
-...the king.
-Come on!
-I know. I know. I know.
It was a crazy week.
We shot all night long
for four nights
at the empty Hollywood Bowl
-Wow!
-in the middle of the night.
Like it was crazy.
It was crazy.
-And you also got
to see yourself animated.
-[ Singsong ]
Yes!
[ Laughter ]
-That was cool.
Was it weird to see you
as a cartoon?
-Well, first of all,
they're still working on it
because animation
is so complicated.
I'm sure you know.
Like it takes so much.
It takes so much work
and it takes so long.
But like when they were
drawing the main girl,
which is me, right?
-Yep.
-They would send me like,
"How do you like this
and you like this?"
And I was just like --
And it's Disney, you know?
It's not just some random --
like it's literally Disney
making an animation
version of me.
-If you're going to do it, yeah,
you might as well do it -- yeah.
But I want to show everyone
you brought a sneak peek
of the concert,
which I appreciate.
Thank you for bringing this.
Here's a look
at "Happier Than Ever:
a Love Letter to Los Angeles."
Check it out.
♪♪
[ Tapping ]
-♪ What would people say ♪
♪ People say, people say? ♪
♪ If they listen
through the wall ♪
♪ the wall, the wall? ♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Yeah, that's how you do it!
Don't mess around Billy Idol
is everyone.
Her new album,
Happier than Ever is out now.
Thank you so much
for being here.